if a person's identity
depends on qualities that can crumble
He or she is in danger of despair for without a sense of self we are nothing, and the world is unmoved by our existence
if everything should fade...
...what will be left of me?
We live in fear of this loss of self our existential crisis
I'm called Lucatiel
I come from Mirrah, a land of knights. My sword is always ready
There is only one way up in Mirrah
Join the order and prove yourself in battle
my family Had little fortune and no name
I had to carve out a piece of the world for myself
with two things:
my sword and my loyalty to my Lord
I was raised to wield a sword from birth
Life was hard
But I never gave it a second thought. I had swift success on the battlefield and quickly attained
respectable stature
And then I...
and then I came here...to
Who are you?
We came to Drangleic seeking answers. Our flesh like many others of humanity is branded with the dark sign of the undead
while marked an undead's memory of their humanity will fade until only a hollow husk remains
Undeath robs us of our past and in doing so, it robs us of our fate
Luccatiel was marked and she bears it with shame, for it forced her out of her homeland
Across many kingdoms the appearance of this curse and those who bear it has been met with fear and hatred
The king of Iron bound the Undead in chains and tortured them endlessly. The current king of light did much the same
Sending them to an inescapable Bastille
It is not so strange to think that the land of Mirrah would have reacted in much the same Manner
damning Lucatiel if it was ever discovered what she had become
Have you heard of the undead?
These poor souls affected by the curse
An undead gradually loses his humanity until his wits degrade completely
Finally he turns hollow and preys upon others. And a hollow can never be human again
One can skirt this wicked fate only with the help of the souls found here
assuming of course that the legends are true
I can only hope...
...that they are
the mask hides Lucatiel's shame
It is said that Drangleic holds the souls that can cure the curse
Many Adventurers rose to the call: some driven by greed, others by desperation.
For Lucatiel Drangleic holds Salvation
I found my thoughts growing hazy
My memories are fading, oldest first
The curse is doing its work upon me. I am frightened
Terribly so. If everything should fade...
...what will be left of me?
Existential despair. The curse took her knighthood, the thing she devoted her life to
Lucatiel's self was based on her prowess as a knight and her loyalty to her lord
Forced to leave Drangleic. What does she have left?
She will lose herself given time. She will lose that which made her what she is
Oh.....
You.
My thoughts... are very... scatttered
What is this curse?
The question rings in my mind, but I haven't the focus to answer it
Loss frightens me no end
Loss of memory. Loss of self
If I were told that by killing you I would be freed of this curse
Then I would draw my sword without hesitation
I don't want to die. I want to exist
I would sacrifice anything
Anything at all for this
It shames me, but it is the truth
Sometimes I feel obsessed with this insignificant thing called self
Even so I am compelled to preserve it
Am I wrong to feel so?
Surely you do the same in my shoes
Maybe we're all cursed
In the moment we're born
All of us face the same despair: Cursed or not there is no meaning in the world beyond what meaning we give it
Despite this we seek meaning, for a life free of purpose simply means that we are able to imprint our own
We are all a product of our past and this shapes our future
But an undead is doomed to lose his past and thus fated to be robbed of his future
Lucatiel has one hope: to find her past and recover who she was
I had an older brother
We learned to fence together
He became the most decorated swordsman in all of Mirrah
I never even compared to him. In fact, I never beat him. Not once
Then, one day
He was gone
Lost without a trace
Now I'm certain that he was taken by the curse
if only someone would hear my tale
My brother must have come here, too
Soon I may forget even about him
An undead gradually loses his humanity until his wits degrade completely
Finally he turns hollow and preys upon others
You...
What's become of you?
my dear brother
I won't die in this foul place
You...
Who are you?
Oh... no
Forgive me. I know you
Yes, of course
How goes your journey?
We find Lucatiel here after her help in countless battles and right before her finding her brother
It is assumed that they have fought, but it is not known
Perhaps she never met him
Perhaps It's better that way, for he has lost himself and attacks others to Rob them of their humanity
Regardless, Lucatiel never progresses further so it is here, outside of Aldia's keep that her journey ends
I know not what you seek in this faraway land
But I pray for your safety
My name is Lucatiel
I beg of you, remember my name
for I may not myself
Existential Despair is a universal human condition. There is no meaning in the world, and yet we seek it... insatiably
Hey guys, if you like that video then you can click the bonfire and become a part of the small group that
supports this channel. It takes you to Patreon where you can give a dollar or two dollars a month to get rewards like seeing videos early
and it really helps me out, and it keeps this channel going. So thank you for watching and I'll see you next time